well ladies and gentlemen good morning
and thank you for coming along to hear
me it's a great honor for me to be one
of the evening speakers at this
conference on National conservatism with
the bright light family and the um
there's no grease painting for Bright
Lights
um National conservatives
uh ladies and gentlemen
you all look very nice people and I'm
sure you are a fantastically nice people
but I would like to draw your attention
too
characteristics of fascism
[Applause]
well there we go our jolly good fellow
eventually but we believe
we believe in freedom of speech so he
can have his National Indians Conference
next week I need to sit down there for
people he gets to come along